oh hold on bro hold on
yo with my two rear piece at
everybody flexing Leon right now bro
with the rare pieces what are you doing
bro you know GQ start acting crazy
what's up yo this is tour I'm rocking
with GQ and you're watching on the rocks
[Music]
I'm not too rare piece I ain't lie I
don't remember the estimate estimate but
I know it's somewhere around like 90. I
had to set a statement everybody had
they changed this I'm the only red
for prior in my city with no chains on
you know I kind of waited my time
so I'm like my first piece about to be
Boston but I gotta go big on them
because they expected some little
out of me so I'm like I'm gonna do the
unexpected you feel me just from Ice
down Customs my homie his name duh I'm
like bro I need a logo I wanted to do
like some Willy Wonka type you feel
me it was like me filming on some
cartoon character on top of it with
the bending on my head like people don't
be peeping that until they really
see that in person
foreign
[Music]
I was actually bored bro I ain't gonna
lie when I came up with this piece I
think I had just recently seen like uh
Drake had popped up with like the
Pharrell piece I'm I gotta do some
iconic like that you feel me yo
where my phone around let me see my
phone I'm gonna show you how I came up
with this bro I actually had to try
to edit this myself
I'm like everybody don't do the Marvel
and DC together you feel me so I'm like
I'm gonna do some different that's
gonna have people talk how you feel me
that's just me Joker guy be the main
drone cause he like he stand out the
most I fly out of everybody but black
panther I had to put the Black Panther
on there at the represent you know
Superman I always with Superman you
feel me I don't say these hoes though
but you know I knew Spider-Man just was
gonna look good on that chain you feel
me but yeah everybody's like bro you
can't do this you can't do that I do
what I want bro I don't give a and
then the marbles
[Music]
a buck or some change
I really got rings I lost probably like
two of them filming me at the airport I
think somebody for me took my I got
some more bigger rings and my heart
one was my next one I know the female
was gonna go crazy about this one so
that's why I had to do them like this
here this one was my next one too
see this piece right here this was
inspired from Radio Raheem
doing the right thing I see how he came
through like the fingers and she had to
love and hate I always wanted like two
drones to go with two but I'm like my
name set up weird so you can't even do
them like that there you feel me this
probably ran me like
[Music]
they always stop me from brass knuckles
they even think I don't care bro
when it's going through the scanner all
they see is like the three OHS and
like some San Andreas GTA so you're
like yo this got brass knuckles or
whatever you feeling me they be cooking
me for sure
EP watch it like 40.
40 something these usually run for like
50 60. that's my second watch actually
my Cartier I don't got it no more me
being a kid it up it got dirty
and I kind of outgrew that you feel
me it's like all right I did this so I'm
like when you get jewelry that should
kind of Be Like You on to the next you
feel me so quick so like I get some big
dog and I got the EP
sure
this is something special
it's from second estate records from the
CEO Mel Carter I'm the first sign I need
for me so this is like something special
he gave it to me he was like yo you got
to go gold or you gotta get on a
freshman cover I did both he didn't made
me work for it bro but yeah I got it
white and rose gold
the piece right there that should shine
different
said Ricky
100 piece that's my dog but I mean
what's his is mines and what's mines is
his so you might catch him with the
underdog piece sometimes it's my A9
but it's like my too so we got Adam
in there because I know y'all be seeing
me with that sometimes you feel me
I ain't no cat but I told you I'm
I'm gonna keep that
of being
this one year it's been a jewelry you
feel me I only got my Cube and like you
see how quickly I'm going to the next
but I might chill you feel me I might go
crazy like for sure for sure
thanks GQ for having me showing my
jewelry off this is just the beginning
don't think I'm running out of money
neither because this is going to
keep adding and piling on so stay tuned
to see my new pieces against
[Music]